"Today, 3 out of the 4 largest financial institutions
are nearly 80 percent bigger
than before we bailed them out because they were too big to fail."
Well, sort of. We didn't bail out all the
big banks, but the biggest U.S. banks are
just as big if not bigger than they were before
the crisis in 2008.
JP Morgan Chase is 75% bigger than it was in 2006. Bank of America is 50%. Wells Fargo is four times
bigger. Only Morgan Stanley and Citigroup
are slightly smaller than they were.
During the height of the crisis, the relatively
healthy banks ended up buying the failing
banks as a way of rescue and these rescues
were backed in some cases by the government.
JP Morgan bought Washington Mutual and Bear
Stearns. Bank of America got Countrywide and
Merrill Lynch. Wells Fargo acquired Wachovia,
a rival that was actually bigger in size.
We've had hundreds of laws and regulations
in the U.S. and around the world to make sure
that the US taxpayer is not on the hook next
time around.
Capital at the biggest five banks on average
is 6%, which is twice as much as it was before
the crisis but it's still miniscule compared
to historic levels.
Eight years after the fall of Lehman Brothers
"Too Big To Fail" is clearly still alive.
There are plenty of opinions about why and
how to deal with it but one thing is for sure
…
Risk in the financial system is still unknown
and can suddenly pop up.
Nobody can be sure that the dominoes won't
start falling again like they did in 2008.
And with banks even bigger now, American taxpayers
may be asked once again to pick up the pieces.